okay hi everyone my name is Vicki today
I'm not gonna show you the most amazing
library in Python that's gonna change
your lives and I'm not gonna give you
the algorithm that's gonna make all your
dreams come true but what I am gonna do
is I'm gonna show you how using the
right technological tools with just the
right amount of willpower can lead to
changes in old industries and I hope
that by the end of my talk I will have
lit a few fires in the crowd so my story
begins about a year and a half ago it
was my first month as related I was just
getting to know my people and and the
office I was having a coffee break just
deleting some emails you know and one of
my friends comes in who's a project
manager and he's also an active sailor
and we get to talking and he starts
telling me were the last time he sailed
and at some point he gets to ranting he
says that whenever he enters a ship he's
forced to listen to all the engines
around him and say if something sounds a
little bit off and he sells a lot so
he's so used to listening to all the
engines that he knows when something
sounds a little bit off and he was
really annoyed like super super annoyed
and I was trying to be nice and I said
oh that sounds horrible I wish there was
an app that listens instead of you and
then will after a moment because
everybody builds apps now and there's
enough for everything for this and for
that but then we stopped laughing and we
looked at each other and we said wait
let's do an app that listens instead of
you so when it comes to software
projects I'm pretty sure I know my
ground I know how a project is supposed
to begin I know how it's supposed to end
I know the between unless my client
decides to change the demands every
other day but this was a totally
different kind of project because it
involved things I never had anything to
do with things like maintenance and
engines and mechanics and whatnot so I
had to start researching so I talked to
a lot of friends who are mechanical
engineers and I talked to Google a lot
and I began researching this old field
of maintenance and I realized that today
in ever
never big company that relies on big
machines they do at least two types of
maintenance the first type is preventive
maintenance for example when I take my
car to the shop I know that every 20,000
the car adds the twenty five thousand
kilometres the car heads I have to go
take it to the shop and come back a few
hours later and get it in like a better
shape so what they do is they clean the
brakes a little bit to prevent anything
faulty in the brakes they touch the
engine little bit to prevent any faults
in the engine and they try to prevent
whatever fault may occur in any of the
mechanical pieces but in two days time I
fly off to Budapest and I need my car to
take me to the airport
what happens if on Thursday morning I go
down the stairs to the parking lot and I
find a very dead car battery what am I
gonna do then then I'm gonna have to
find a fix for the fault and that's the
second type of maintenance that's being
performed
it's breakdown maintenance it's we
couldn't prevent the fault from
happening and now we have to find a fix
now when it comes to cars it's a little
bit inconvenient I know we have to take
the bus maybe you have to take two buses
to work maybe we have to take the train
god forbid and the trains they get
cancelled at the time but when it comes
to vessels it's a little bit more
difficult than that because vessels they
have to perform their missions and when
an engine breaks and one of the vessels
then it can perform its missions and
then other vessels may need to perform
its missions for it
and what about spare parts if spare
parts are within the country where good
luck
but sometimes spare parts we have to fly
them over from a different country and
that we have to wait for the shipment to
come in and then you get stuck in
customs and then when it's finally in
Israel technicians they have to move
from their regular jobs and they have to
go and try and find a fix right now and
they can perform their missions either
so it's one business so preventive
maintenance doesn't prevent all types of
failures we can't really say that come
to the shop every 20,000 kilometres and
everything will be fine
breakdown maintenance is the worst case
scenario isn't there anything we can do
in between the two well there is there's
this magical word
predictive means I'm sure everybody's
heard of this word the the the meaning
of predictive maintenance we try to
predict the faults before it happens and
the basis of this assumption is we need
to know the engine itself as well as we
as well as we can and that's how we
predict the fault now in like many
things that have happened in the past
many great things that have happened in
the past predictive maintenance also
began at NASA somewhere in the beginning
of the 90s a bunch of mechanical
engineers were sitting around a table
yelling at each other we're not doing
maintenance well enough we have to do it
efficiently and in order to test this
theory they took a hundred engines and
they collected some data and they did
some really simple equations it was
really the beginning of the beginning of
predictive maintenance and they found
out that out of the 100 engines that
were supposed to go into a preventive
maintenance routine only four actually
needed and then they began their massive
research and predictive maintenance and
they're like top of the world right now
so how is it done basically in the past
in the past couple of decades it was
done based on a physical model a
physical model means we have to know the
engines as well as we can we have to
know how they move how they sound how
the oil is supposed to be we have to
know everything there is to know about
the engine now how do you know
everything there is to know about the
engine there are a lot of methods you
can do it via vibrational analysis where
your features are a velocity and
acceleration or oil analysis where your
features are the health of the oil or
the contamination of the oil and stuff
like that acoustic analysis frequency is
the feature and many more so for our
project we began going in this direction
we said okay let's try doing doing it
with the physical model and see what we
can get so we started we start
researching the vibration analysis and
vibration analysis this is something we
really like because it sounds amazing
allows the user to evaluate the
condition of equipment and avoid
failures sounds amazing right and then
we said okay it sounds great they do
their work behind this
and then they have a really friendly UI
because they know the client has to be
happy and I can actually see the picture
of the engine and a lot of green and red
dots saying this part is good this part
is faulty but there's one big problem
with this with this method and if we
need a mechanical engineer with us every
step of the way and a vibration analyst
is an actual profession this is
something I didn't know it's something
you have to learn and you have to be
super experienced in order to make to
make the model as accurate as we need it
to be so it's not like I can open a
YouTube tutorial and see hey guys in the
next four minutes I'm gonna show you how
to become a vibration analyst it doesn't
work that way unfortunately so we had to
move on and research another method the
second method we researched was really
what was done at NASA we said okay NASA
know what they're doing let's let's see
what they're doing so they took a
slightly different features they took
current and voltage and they did the
whole process a lot more efficiently
because they automated it they said okay
we're gonna automate the data collection
and the analysis tasks and we thought
okay this sounds great we can use this
method but then but then we found three
downsides not just one the first
downside is of course in order to make
the model as accurate as we want we need
to put a lot of sensors now nASA has
infinite budget the Navy doesn't have
infinite but it's not a secret and the
second the second part is most sensors I
know you probably all know sensors and
most sensors that are accurate and
they're good they they have a Bluetooth
or Wi-Fi technology within them and the
third problem was the same problem from
before even if everything is automated
the data collections automated the
analysis tests are automated we still
need when the warning when there's
warnings we're still in a mechanical
engineer in the control room saying what
it is so we need a mechanical engineer
every step of the way from the beginning
in the middle and all the way until the
end and then we said okay we don't have
mechanical engineers just lying around
waiting for us to give them tasks I'm a
computer engineer my partner was an
electrical engineer
what are we
I said okay let's go find machine
learning solutions I don't know and then
we looked at the data science model now
the data science model as you probably
all know it's a model that is based on
the data we only need mechanical
engineers at the beginning we need
mechanical engineers to tell us how to
look at the data and how to process the
data and how to skip skip pass stuff we
don't want to hear and how to make the
model as accurate as we want but then
after we have an accurate model we can
actually continue by on our own we don't
need mechanical engineers holding our
hands all along at this point you might
ask yourselves this is what happened to
me you had a working model you had
people who performed their jobs they're
doing predictive maintenance as a
profession why go and push ml why look
at new new models what why enter a world
that's already nobody has entered it
before in the in the Navy at least and
the answer to that is quite simple I'm
not a mechanical engineer and I really
wanted to do this project but the second
thing is if we look at if we look at
classic algorithms for example face
recognition if we if we were to do a
rule based algorithm on face recognition
we would fail completely because there
are too many rules there's just too many
rules for me and that's why I moved from
rule based algorithm to data science
algorithms what happens in vessels is
maybe in the past they were like I don't
know three systems on a vessel and
everything was really simple and nice
today there are hundreds of vessels and
all the sounds they get they interfere
with one another and there's just too
much noise and we can't just do a set of
rules that is good and and finds all the
problems and has all the solutions
that's why we decide to move the
responsibility for building the set of
rules to the data so we began looking at
the supervised learning we said okay
supervised learning is easy we'll map an
input to an output based on example
input-output pairs if we look at the
former example its faces to names if we
look at our project its engine sounds to
working not working we had to start
where we couldn't start from a huge
vessel with a lot of engines talking to
each other we had to start from just one
engine but then we said what if a
foreign fleet for example has a hundred
types of vessel but still Avis will be
this Aussie and every type of vessel has
like I don't know 40 40 ships each type
and each type of vessel has 50 engines
inside of it and they're all different
from one another and they're all
different between the vessels themselves
it's too much information to tag I don't
have the manpower I didn't have the
manpower a year ago and I don't have the
manpower right now and what if what if I
need to change something somewhere in
the next couple of months
I will finish tagging and then I will I
have a new engine entering the database
I have to take it a few months from now
I need to have a manpower and a few in a
few months from now that's something I
couldn't I couldn't agree with there's
something that I couldn't do with my
project and so we moved on to the
unsupervised method and then we said
okay unsupervised method we don't need
to set in tag for a year now we can just
find patterns from a data set without
reference to known or labeled outcomes
and we found the two methods in the
unsupervised and the unsupervised method
in the unsupervised approach I fit our
problems the first one was clustering
clustering allows you automatically to
split the data set into groups and this
could solve is the problem of for
example if we have a sensor and the
sensor collects data from three engines
that are aligned up against each other
because we don't have sensors on each
and every one of the mechanical pieces
in the vessel of course clustering can
help us define which which which of the
information the sensor collects belongs
to which of the engines so that's the
first part that unsupervised helped us
solve and the second part was the
anomaly detection once we had three
different groups of three different
engines we could take one of the groups
one of the engines and try to find
anomalies for example if engine a makes
the sound a all the time whenever there
was a B or a C or D the the system was
supposed to find it
to find this anomaly and this is
something that fits our project now our
project is not the first nor last
project that's going to use data science
for predictive maintenance and for those
of you who work in the car industry you
probably know that the car industry is
way ahead of every other industry in the
world and every R&D center that respects
itself has a division that deals only
with predictive maintenance via data
science and NASA of course their big
experts and and but but it doesn't have
to be it doesn't have to be just cars or
just chips or just space shuttles it can
be anything
for example for example one of my
friends in her company they try to map
out map and map out all the hard drives
and test the reliability and they didn't
call it predictive maintenance I don't
think but but they actually did it they
collected data and then they tested
their hard drives and now they know the
state of each and every one of their
hard drives and whoever view who wants
to try and test some data themselves and
there's a really good link I can share
with you that has about 15 data sets of
different types of engines of space
shuttles and that's really nice but NASA
gives it to us for free
now imagine a world where you enter your
car and you can actually see the
mechanic state of each and every one of
the mechanical pieces within the car
that's amazing right but it's not the
future it's the present and some places
it's already the past and the same as it
is for the car industry in the same as
it is for NASA I want the same for my
ship and that's why I'm pursuing this
this project now data science as you all
know was is very good and we need to use
data science for we need Tuesday designs
for a big range of projects not just
personalization of products or
personalization of events on Facebook
and stuff like that there's a really big
range of stuff we can do and it's really
interesting even if it's just if it's
old machines or stuff like that so we
know the data science is the bridge
between the old world of
and the new world of machines that learn
and this is where I invite you all to do
predictive maintenance with me thank you
did you combine the features for all the
three domains baby science project which
determines that cool Steve I know we
used only acoustic because this is what
fits our project but what if we see that
the model is not accurate enough we
could move to vibration this is
something we're considering you need to
know if anything will work when we speak
about maintenance what it's mean
maintenance because if you decide the
example from your result the engine will
not work then somebody after changing
the big promise the big promise of
predictive maintenance is it's not that
we stopped doing preventive maintenance
or we stopped doing breakdown
maintenance his predictive maintenance
we can stop doing breakdown maintenance
because we can predict the fall before
it happens
but also because we know the exact state
of the engine we know how to schedule
correctly the preventive maintenance not
every three months or every 20,000 K or
just a number that comes out of a head
it's made by the state the actual state
of each and every one of the engines so
it doesn't it doesn't it's not either/or
it's everything together just more
efficient they conceal some when you get
our foundation yes it acquired before no
we only tried one format but it's good
enough for us it's something that I
agree that maybe in the pen maybe in the
present and maybe in the future we'll
try other formats but this one works for
us for the meantime but it's a good
thing to think about
thank you if anybody has further
questions
[Applause]